l'histoire fait la manchette depuis hier
au centre et une à montréal il ya des
agents de sécurité qui ont demandé à une
femme d'arrêter d'allaiter son bébé sur
le banc où elle s'est installée et de se
rendre plutôt dans une salle
d'allaitement privé du centre commercial
on croyait pourtant que la question de
l'allaitement public était réglée depuis
des années socialement mais aussi sur le
plan légal alors pour en parler et pour
démêler tout ça je joins et louise
langevin elle est professeur de droit à
l'université laval - madame langevin
n'y a pas de loi spécifique entre que je
me suis demandé ce matin j'ai remarqué
qu avait pas de loi spécifique qui
encadraient l'allaitement dans certains
lieux mais le droit et quand même
protégée par les chartes
oui oui dans la situation que vous
soulevez ici la charte des droits et
libertés du québec
sa clique parce que c'est un cas
d'atteinte au droit à l'égalité de cette
femme là la jurisprudence est très
claire sur le sujet à toutes les fois
qu'il ya un traitement
différent un traitement différent
négatif finit par rapport à la grossesse
par rapport aux capacités procréative
des femmes c'est de la discrimination
fondée sur le sexe parce que ici madame
qui elle était a été traité différemment
des autres personnes qui étaient dans le
même espace public on a dit à cette
femme là parce qu'elle allaitait d'aller
ailleurs justement on lui est pas
interdit d'aller t on lui a demandé de
se déplacer dans une salle qui réservait
cet effet là est-ce que c'est
problématique quand même oui c'est
problématique parce que elle parce
qu'elle allaitait elle ne pouvait pas
rester dans l'espace public comme les
autres personnes qui n'arrêtait pas donc
qu'on lui dise d'aller dans une autre
pièce réservée à cet effet là ça porte
atteinte à son droit à l'égalité parce
qu'elle est une femme parce qu'elles
allaitent et donc c'est de la
discrimination fondée sur le sexe par
produit parce que ce traitement
différent j'exclus de l'espace public et
reproduit des stéréotypes des préjugés à
l'égard des femmes allaitantes à l'égard
de la grossesse c'est quelque chose que
l'on cache c'est quelque chose on ne
parle pas de ça donc c'est imposer une
certaine moralité de ce qui est bien et
de ce qui m'arrive donc produit des
stéréotypes en disant aux femmes vous
restez dans l'espace privé et la pièce
pour allaiter c'est bien cette
distinction à la sphère publique et la
sphère et cette femme a été exclue de la
spa bon évidemment ça montre ce titre
alors que beaucoup d'éducation à faire
encore on pensait qu'on avait réglé ça
mais non on peut se demander s'il faut
commencer par demander aux employeurs de
donner des consignes très claires à
leurs employés sur tous ceux qui
travaillent dans des endroits comme
comme des centres commerciaux par
exemple mais là on comprend qu'ils
avaient une certaine consignes quand ce
sont des gestes intimes et privés ces
gestes ne peuvent pas éviter dans les
lieux publics mais c'est toute la
question de l'interprétation le qu'est
ce qu'un geste intime et privée intime
et privé les les agents de sécurité vont
t'ils s'interposer si on s'embrasse à
exactement j'ai pas un souci aux
questions de d'embrassades ou de payer
plus prolongeant l'espace public gip a
certains qui vont intervenir mais ici
sur ce qui est intime et privée de
considérer que l'allaitement est quelque
chose d'intimé privé c'est toute l'image
du sein et des saints l'espace public
justement je vais vous entendre là
dessus parce que on voit des médias
sociaux qui sont sur des photos
d'allaitement
mais comment on peut expliquer ça quand
on voit quand on sait tout ce qui
circule sur les réseaux sociaux sur le
net en matière de nudité c'est difficile
de faire mieux
oui tout à fait mais c'est encore cette
idée du sein dès qu'il y a un sens un
peu importe qu'ils soient sûrs alloués
way sur une toile une maquette en train
d'allaiter ou d'un des comportements
plus sexuellement explicites c'est que
le saint est à la fois sa réalité mais
est aussi et je dirai rien
désiré
spécialement dans une société
patriarcale hétérosexuels ou
c'est l'autre qui regarde qui décide que
c'est injuste intime que c'est un geste
déplacé mais on voit donc bien comment
leur faire des femmes et l'auteur des
femmes qui allaient dans l'espace public
est contrôlée existe qu est ce que ces
employés l'ont fait les contrôles et
madame en deçà ceci est un geste chacune
au public c'est un geste déplacé vous
faites ça ailleurs donc on voit bien le
contrôle du corps des femmes et le
contrôle de la femme dans ses capacités
créatives
il se peut très bien que où était située
cette femme de ce centre d'achat
peut-être y avait-il une boutique juste
à côté où on rendait des maillots de
bains et piscines et des sous-vêtements
aussi très petit donc c'est pour vous
montrer le jugement des femmes et vous
le faites toujours très clairement
louise langevin professeure de droit
merci beaucoup de nous avoir parlé
aujourd'hui merci bonsoir à voir